Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
hoy nos acompaña Daniel ders medalla de
plata en BMX freestyle Park en los
Juegos Olímpicos de Tokio y sobre todo
una leyenda de este deporte nacido en
Venezuela Daniel Gracias por
acompañarnos un placer para mí Gracias
por tomarse el tiempo Este es un año de
muchísimas competencias por supuesto con
los ojos puestos sobre París 2024 Cómo
va la preparación para los Juegos
Olímpicos va bien Yo comencé hace dos
semanas en Paraguay ganó el Campeonato
continental
de ahí fui a Japón a los extens y ahora
me encuentro aquí en montpellier en la
persecución de los puntos para poder
entrar al a la serie del comité olímpico
internacional que está haciendo el año
que viene que nos da unas plazas
directas al mismo tiempo este año el
mundial nos da unas plazas directas y el
Mundial del año pasado también la manera
en que funciona es que dependiendo lo
que pase el año que viene se van
sorteando para las de este año y para el
año anterior
entonces este aumento Bueno tengo un par
de tareas distintas una tratar de
mantenerme en el ranking para poder
clasificar hacer el año que viene y al
mismo tiempo este año darle fuerte al
mundial porque estoy como estratega yo
necesito
posicionarme lo mejor que pueden en el
mundial en caso de que el año que viene
me da mal porque uno nunca sabe uno
puede tener un golpe una lesión algo
entonces estoy en eso en este momento y
me siento bien me siento contento aquí
montpellier siempre es el evento tal vez
más difícil del año porque es el más
grande Precisamente en cuanto a la
preparación Cómo es la preparación
física y mental hay un punto donde es
más importante lo físico que lo mental
como es todo esto para Daniel ders claro
hay un poquito de todo creo que lo más
importante es mantenerte siempre activo
yo siempre estoy constantemente yendo al
gimnasio dependiendo de la temporada del
año yo me especifico en un tipo de
programación más específica ahorita
estuve un mes y medio en Venezuela
entrenando para lo que es este comienzo
de mi temporada
y de verdad me siento bastante bien veo
que la tarea funcionó luego está la
parte de montar bici que siempre la más
importante necesitas montar bicicleta
todos los días ya que uno puede llegar a
perder la agilidad cuando paras Entonces
estás constantemente practicando luego
bueno tienes la parte emocional que te
hace feliz no al final del día porque al
competir es estresante O sea estás
Tienes un minuto para demostrar lo que
viene haciendo en meses o en años y ese
momento a veces pesa porque si no
pudiste entrenar bien ese en ese
circuito dormiste mal la noche anterior
se sabe cualquier cantidad de cosas se
te pueden pasar entonces tiene que estar
mentalmente preparado y fuerte y
esperarlo inesperado y bueno en este
caso también tienes dos tipos de
estrategia no tienes la clasificación
que es mucho más tediosa porque es mucho
más larga necesitas meses para lograrlo
y luego tienes la preparación específica
de los Juegos Olímpicos que una vez que
te dan el circuito con tiempo uno puede
preparar más en específico lo que
necesitas para bueno eficiente con tu
tiempo el día que estés ahí en la
práctica para París el objetivo cuál es
lograr el oro esta vez Mira vamos paso a
paso primero clasificar el número uno
una vez clasifique la idea sería
despedirse con honor ya que el año Ya
que en Tokio 2020 quedamos de plata me
gustaría claro especialmente Venezuela
que no tenemos muchas medallas de oro me
gustaría poderle dar esa alegría sí sé
que es una tarea difícil porque del
ciclo anterior a este han aparecido unas
caras nuevas que tienen mucho potencial
mucho mucho potencial yo creo que me
afinco mucho en la experiencia y así es
que a veces logro ganarles
es más difícil durante el año para mí
por mi preparación yo necesito
preparaciones más específicas para los
eventos Entonces vamos a ver creo que
una vez que tengamos ya el circuito
diseñado lo podamos ver podamos
practicar creo que puedo afinar mi
estrategia para bueno dar las tocada
final porque ahí yo yo me pienso retirar
Ya el año que viene me retiro van a ser
mis los Juegos Olímpicos Así que
Precisamente en cuanto a la preparación
cuando decías hay unos talentos cada vez
O sea más fuertes pero también muy
jóvenes Eso hace que que en la
preparación
tú ya sea como te empuje más a
mantenerse a un cierto nivel o es la
experiencia la que va a jugar mucho
también Creo que es la disciplina tú mi
disciplina me ha mantenido
presente en el deporte a esta altura ya
yo tengo 18 años compitiendo profesional
y logré entrar los Juegos Olímpicos
cuando yo pensé que me iba a retirar y
logré ganar una medalla olímpica
entonces
no es tanto lo que ellos hacen es lo que
yo puedo hacer y claro yo estoy
pendiente de más que todos los trucos
que hacen que es lo nuevo que hace O sea
que rumbo está agarrando el deporte
porque Bueno ya hoy en día o sea en su
momento fui parte de esa dirección del
deporte pero ya la nueva generación es
quien dirige hacia Qué tipo de trucos
vamos entonces eso lo que tal vez estoy
más pendiente lo que hacen para
prepararme a sea un poco más difícil en
ese sentido ellos aprenden cosas mucho
más rápido imagínate un truco que yo Tal
vez tarde dos años en aprenderlo yo
ahora ellos lo aprenden en una semana
Entonces a veces hay cosas que a nivel
de truco también el Imagínate yo tengo
38 años yo cuando voy a arriesgar Yo lo
pienso dos veces yo lo Yo tengo un
proceso mental diferente a un niño que
tiene 20 años que no le importa nada en
la vida lo que quiere es ganar ese
primer evento entonces a mí me alegra
mucho verlos ganar su primer evento me
parece excelente pero ahí es cuando la
cosa se pone más pareja porque gana la
primera vez no es tan difícil pero
continuar ganando es lo que te lo hace
bastante complicado necesitas esa
disciplina Ahora tienes expectativa
Ahora sabes lo que puedes lograr
Entonces yo ahí donde mefinco en la
experiencia yo tengo la experiencia de
yo he ganado y he perdido yo sé cómo se
sienten las dos cosas yo sé cuando gano
quién me está viendo cuando pierdo que
me están viendo ya Ya eso lo entiendo
ellos todavía no tanto Entonces es
interesante ver ese proceso en ellos y
bueno una vez más donde ellos son muy o
más fuertes que yo también hay un lado
donde yo soy mucho más fuerte que ellos
y en el final del día Hay que montar la
bicicleta y ver quién le va mejor
justamente París 2024 es digamos Ya el
final de de la carrera de Daniels En
todo caso en cuanto a Juegos Olímpicos
pero viene también ese lado un poco
mentor porque de alguna manera usted
pues ha sido como ese mentor para para
muchos nuevas generaciones de BMX
alrededor del mundo y ahora viene
también este trabajo con con china
entrenando a ese equipo de BMX cuéntenos
un poco acerca de esto creo que desde
siempre me ha gustado enseñar y me
acuerdo mi mentor hace muchos años me
decía Daniel eventualmente uno tiene que
devolverle al deporte ya sea con eventos
con instrucción con lo que sea y fue
algo que quedó conmigo y siempre lo he
hecho o sea Incluso en estos últimos
años con Nikita con Hannah que bueno
ganaron medallas olímpicas con Perris
también bueno de lado los hombres con
Justin parte del equipo americano
sabes como que siempre los pongo debajo
de mi ala y trato de darle un poquito de
guía tampoco le va a dar todos los
secretos porque estamos compitiendo pero
siempre me ha gustado Y hace poco salió
la oportunidad de trabajar con el equipo
nacional de China porque el lado
femenino tiene mucho potencial de
clasificar e incluso de ganar medalla
que lo que pasa en China el deporte es
muy nuevo ellos no tienen tal vez la
experiencia que requiere y Yo comencé
con ellos hace dos tres días o sea estoy
muy reciente y está muy avanzado en las
cosas que hacen lo cual me gusta y me ha
facilitado el trabajo pero noto donde
viene mi experiencia porque a veces
estamos Armando la rutina y es como de
no Mira esto en el papel se ve muy
bonito pero en la práctica no es así
porque esto lo otro sabes es muy loco
porque tú ves la ronda final no Y tú
sabes qué bonito minuto pero uno piensa
Ok si hay viento que va a hacer el sol
Dónde está saliendo esa hora o sea tú
cómo tienes que pensar deje tener todo
en el plato para ver cómo te lo vas a
comer entonces estoy emocionado porque
sé que es algo que me gusta yo justo el
año pasado empecé a practicar mandarín
me llamó la atención empecé a
practicarlo y sale lo de China este año
entonces quisiera Espero poder
perfeccionar el idioma ahora que el que
el París son los últimos Juegos
Olímpicos de danielsy seguramente ya
pensando un final de carrera La idea es
ir hacia hacia esto a convertirse en
entrenador hacer digamos en mentores
ciento por ciento creo que siempre de
alguna manera o de otra va a ser mentor
porque es algo como te digo que me
apasiona me gusta
el yo Bueno espero ser un mejor trabajo
que pueda con la selección de China este
evento es como el más es el piloto
porque yo también estoy compitiendo y
necesitamos ver si en realidad al final
el día Todo funciona pero hasta ahora
vamos bien
Me gustaría saber lograr que ellas
lleguen a esas medallas que sería el
sueño porque aparte hay como doble
satisfacción no como Rider y ahora como
como entrenador como mentor oficial
creo que para el futuro voy a estar
involucrado en el deporte todavía yo
pienso seguir montando bici lo que no va
a estar es compitiendo pero a mí me
gusta venir a los eventos me gusta ver
cómo está la los corredores el nivel no
sé si siento por alguna razón que va a
terminar involucrado en la organización
ya sea en el piso en el comité olímpico
o en algún lugar del Matrix del deporte
porque es algo que me gusta también hago
proyectos en Venezuela yo la fundación
del año pasado háblanos un poquito de
eso Mira la misión de la fundación es
poder darle esas herramientas a los
atletas en Venezuela para poder lograr
sus sueños por ejemplo Yo comencé la
academia de hace un año también y es
para enseñar a los atletas esas
habilidades que no nos enseña a ti te
dicen ser mejor en bicicleta y más nada
pero el día que llega a la cámara Cómo
hablas necesitas aprender pues no todo
yo no sabía hablar yo era incluso muy
tímido y tuve que aprender a comunicarme
con la cámara Cómo haces si se acerca un
niñito Cómo se te acerca alguien con una
discapacidad un presidente un país o sea
necesita saber comunicarte también saber
cómo generar tus recursos y cómo
administrarlos entonces todo eso
decidimos crear la academia la cual
bueno parte del
de la manera que sea gratuita para los
atletas a través de la fundación que
recibe donaciones para poder fundar esos
proyectos También tenemos la idea de
generar infraestructura en Venezuela en
algún momento lo cual es un poco más
complejo va a tardar más tiempo pero es
parte de nuestra misión Porque si yo no
te doy las herramientas como tú vas a
poder hacerlo no entonces esa es parte
también de nuestra misión por último se
puede decir que hay un hay un relevo
para Daniel ders después una vez usted
se retire hay un relevo en Venezuela
mira en realidad en Venezuela Creo va
toma un poquito más de tiempo y es por
eso de que no hay lugares donde entrenar
y o sea los que hay no están bien
construidos y es muy difícil no comparas
las manzanas con las Manzanas entrenar
en Venezuela versus entrenar venía una
copa mundo posible hoy en día en el
nivel y por eso mi interés de tratar de
crear esa infraestructura de alguna
manera para que en los próximos diez
años sí lo haya por el deporte aparte
toma tiempo no es algo que tú lo tienes
y en un mes Eres el mejor toma tiempo
entonces parte de eso es poder crear ese
relevo porque bueno Sabes Yo soy de
Venezuela yo creo que hay un venezolano
en el BMX en algún momento bueno
tomándolo recogiendo la cosecha que yo
hice o sea porque bueno Yo fui el
primero estamos estábamos comenzando con
todo esto Entonces ese sí me interesa si
quiero que suceda no estamos ahí todavía
pero vamos a llegar muy bien pues
esperamos allá cosecho de talentos
cosecha de medallas Ojalá en París Y
muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado gracias
Y ustedes Gracias también por continuar
con nosotros y continúen con nuestra
programación en France 24.com
[Música]